-Amy, we mentioned Hellmann's.
You're doing a Super Bowl ad
This is your third
Super Bowl ad.
That's quite an accomplishment
-What? Well, you know.
I mean, no,
it really is exciting
to be in a Super Bowl ad.
You know,
you're watching the game,
and then you're like, "Ah!
But you know how it is.
No, I've never been asked
to be in one, so...
-Oh, my God.
You should do one.
You get so much money.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Yeah, Seth, you should get into
a Super Bowl commercial.
-Such good advice.
-Oh, my God.
You have been missing out.
Yeah.
It is -- But you know what
And I'm proud to be --
I like to say,
"But Hellmann's approached me,
like as if I were at a bar
and, like, a jar of mayo came --
like, sidled up and was like..
But really, they reached out
And, you know,
you have to be conscious
of the companies
you're partnering with now
You don't want to be like,
"And guess what
It's made by children!"
So I'm really proud with how
they're handling everything.
And their business model
and they are doing so much
to try to help people
with food insecurity.
And also, they agreed --
And this is the coolest thing.
They agreed to make
their best efforts
to not have the ad appear before
any videos with hate speec
or disinformation,
which is, you know,
such a major problem right now
And other actors and performer
can get that
in their contracts, too.
-I know that you sort of spend
a lot of time on social media,
and we actually talked
about wanting to, like,
disengage from it
when we've had conversations
Like, how do you respond
to Internet hate?
-Well, I-I think they're right
And I retire.
No, you know, I think
it kind of keeps me honest
Like, I don't mind at all.
And me partnering
with mayonnaise,
like, I really think
that there will be
some great memes
born out of this.
And, you know,
it's the same thing
with, like, the Internet trolls.
It's like,
I have always thought --
No, I've always known
that I'm cute.
Like, I'm just like, "I'm cute
I'm sorry."
I posted a picture
of my C-section yesterday
because I'm like,
"I think it's cute."
I hope more people can just,
like, trust themselves,
you know, in that way.
And, yes, I'm partnering
with mayonnaise.
And I think that is sexy.
You know, my good friend
Jennifer Lawrence
is the face of Dior,
and I am the body of mayo.
-You have a beautiful baby boy
Gene.
How old is Gene now?
-He's fine, he's fine.
No, I'm just kidding.
-How old is Gene?
-Gene.
I know he's older than 1,
obviously.
-So can you just not remembe
Gene's age?
-No, no.
I do know how old Gene is.
Of course!
He's my roommate.
But he -- The thing is --
Okay, he's gonna turn 2 in May
But, like, that's an annoying --
There's no way
that's not annoying
to tell someone
how old your kid is, you know?
It's like, "Okay,
he's gonna be 2 in May.
I have to do a math problem.
Get out your cellphone
calculator."
Or, "He's 20 months."
It's like, "Is he the Messia
that we're talking about him
with that kind of --"
So I've decided
just to lie, actually.
So ask me again how old he is.
-How old is Gene?
-11.
-Perfect. [ Laughs ]
-Good, right?
That's the way to go, lie.
-It's a very effective way
to answer the question.
I want to ask this, as well.
You know, so much
of this parenting,
as I'm finding out, as well,
you're constantly judging
how you think you're doing
Do you feel
like you are a good mom?
-Actually, no.
It's interesting.
You know, you don't know
how good you're gonna be
of a parent.
And I got some nice advice
from Natalie Portman,
who was like,
"You have more instincts
than you know you have."
And what I'm finding is that
Natalie Portman is a huge liar
Because so far my instinct
are all just dead wrong.
And I've been reading
this parenting book
"How Toddlers Thrive,"
and all my instincts, like -
Usually if Chris and I are gonna
leave Gene with the nanny,
we sneak out, you know?
We literally, like, you know
like a creep in a cartoon.
We're like -- You know, or I'l
just drop down behind the couc
and kind of like do The Matrix
just so he doesn't cry
and freak out.
And this book, like,
page one is like,
"Whatever you do,
don't sneak out.
That's really bad
for your child."
And I'm like, "Okay."
I mean, not to mention tha
we did name him, you know,
by accident, "Genital," which we
all saw in the carrot video.
It was kind of foreshadowing
for the carrot.
-This is -- For those --
Again, for who those
who haven't heard the story,
you named your son Gene,
and then his middle name
was after the comedian
and your friend Dave Attell.
So it was Gene Attell.
-Right.
-Which you did not realize
until you heard it out lou
sounded like "genital."
-That's right.
What sucks now
is that you can never
make fun of another kid's name
You know, when a celebrity
has a baby
and they name it
something stupid,
you can't be like,
"Nice name, idiot."
'Cause it's like, "Well, wha
did you name your kid, Amy
Why didn't you just name him
Ballsack Wiener?
Wiener Tip?
How about that, Amy?"
No, I am not --
Thank God I have --
I call my friends from home.
We all just share advice
with each other.
But my instincts are really bad.
They're really poor,
but what's good,
you just have to live and learn,
don't you think?
It's like at first, it's lik
we'd be at the playground
or something, and he'd have,
like, a meltdown.
And I just wish that Ghost
of Christmas Future Mom Me
could tell Ghost
of Christmas Past Me Mom,
"Hey, you know how he's
freaking out on the playground
Well, he's gonna
do this so often
that you're gonna
become desensitized
and not be able
to feel it anymore,
and that's something
you can look forward to."
-Before we go, Amy,
I do want to take a quick look
at what we can expect from you
Super Bowl Hellmann's commercial
this Sunday.
-Did you shoot
a Super Bowl commercial?
-No.
-No, it was me!
Oh, right.
Okay. Go ahead.
Sorry about that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Scanner beeping ]
-Cleanup in aisle six.
-What, are you having
a potato salad party?
-[ Laughs ]
-Do you have a bag?
-I mean, I could have done that.
-Take that, Glenda Jackson
-I could have done that.
You couldn't have thrown a bon
to your friend Seth.
-You should have thrown in
your head shot.
Send your head shot
to Hellmann's.
-To who? To you?
-They're open.
Yeah, send your head shot to me,
and I'll consider it.
I'll consider it.
-Thanks for being here.
I miss you.
I hope to see you soon.
-Miss you.
-Do not miss Amy's
Hellmann's commercial,
airing this Sunday
during the Super Bowl.